listening to a film courage women
and caring
I think realistically it's like anything
in life I think you have to properly
assess your ability I think people that
miscalculate and Miss misinterpret what
they have in any certain field there's a
big difference between wanting to do
something and being able to do something
and you really have to check your ego at
the door to say am I couldn't be
competitive with this cross-section of
talent and you know a lot of times you
watch some of the reality shows today
and it's just ever-present you know you
watch American Idol and some of these
people truly believe that they can sing
and you can look in their eyes and they
truly believe they're dumbfounded why
they didn't make it past the first round
and the whole audience is like oh my god
you can't carry a tune not one to I
think you have to properly assess you
have to be honest with yourself and say
I can be competitive with this
cross-section and if you're fairly
accurate to that mark I think you have a
good shot you know and that goes with
any field you know certainly you're not
there's not a lot of people that want to
be a you know fluid dynamics engineers
that can't you know do do mathematics
you know they can't write an algorithm
certainly that's a prerequisite you have
to be honest with yourself and your
professor is going to tell you you know
you don't need to know string theory but
you need to know fundamentals of math
know maybe Simon Cowell isn't as bad as
a saving people time you know what I
mean it really isn't this industry it's
a harsh reality you know you need to let
somebody know and and it may be
unfortunate but realistically what would
you rather would you rather somebody
call you know keep at it keep trying
somebody that's like sounds like a dog
dying really or do you want somebody
that may may hurt their feelings for a
day but at least they're gonna pursue
something that they can actually achieve
something